live from Korea and what is it 11:36
p.m. over there it is it is it's late
night time how are you I'm good Fritzie
wanted to know if we could do pewter or
zinc or something like that with has
there been any talk of that Mike you get
certificates for finishing I think or
through ace I want to say they give you
a certificate which is the akin to the
participation trophy but nothing other
pewter medals just yet but I will get
our research right on it
change that to change the IOC wants to
make based on fritzy's suggestion
what is the level of us fan presence in
Pyeongchang it's it's light I think the
level of fan presence in general is
light I would say that I tried to get
out to an event over the weekend and
there was a lot of traffic it was Lunar
New Year and there was a lot of fans who
came from what they saw or more
populated areas of South Korea the
weekend events had good coverage I think
we've seen a lot of empty seats during
daytime events especially during the
week and I think part of it is where we
are it is more of a mountainous remote
area you're not near a huge city like
Seoul and I think it's also the distance
now for folks to come out here they had
to really commit so it's pretty this way
a lot less than we saw it real and
certainly a lot less than North American
Olympics for American fans who came over
just to experience the games star the
game so far is mm that's a good way for
for us fans I think it's a little bit
difficult you don't know somebody named
Marcel here sure who's a skier who has
won two gold medals and his best event
the slalom is coming up so he has a
chance to win three gold medals in an
Olympics that has only happened three
times from an alpine skier in the
history of the games so right now he
would be I don't think he look at you
know anybody else in the sports are we
following the US and say this is
when a standout athlete a top-up of
performance multiple gold medals or
anything else so for the moment I would
say that for for the American viewers it
I don't know if there's one that would
stand out because the Chloe Kim and
Shawn white everybody performs his for
goal they were good enough I'm also
curious I brought this up at the
beginning of the show that we watched
for a week some of these sports that we
only watch every couple of years and
then we become an expert in skeleton
correct right exactly and sports but we
don't watch period yeah you know how you
know I'm right unless you watch X Games
and watch other competitions like that
you don't watch a lot of snow where do
you your listeners those of us who watch
sports on a regular basis and that's the
unique part of the Olympics with we
judge it under the sports category but
it's always been there but your
viewership last night let's say a lot of
people who are watching who wouldn't
have been watching the NBA all-star game
so they weren't making a choice but
there are some of us who get caught up
in it who would have watched either one
so it is such a broad approach that you
and I talked about this in real the
Olympics is such a unique and different
entity compared to anything else we deal
with in terms of who watches the
crossover appeal and especially in the
Winter Games the nuances of these sports
that most of us didn't grow up doing
it's not like you go down to the park
they hit guys or jump on a luge rope
ready you were wrong so we can't
associate us our our experiences
athletically what we're watching on TV I
gotta believe that the people who do
skeleton have to talk trash to those who
do luge now calling him soft I mean
skeleton looks like of all of those
sports that might be as scary you know
I'm leading with my face here Mike
that's the question we were throwing
that question around as a matter of fact
I don't like you play there v I think
during the daytime show either today or
tomorrow Rebecca Lowe was hosting the
daytime where everyone knows if they
watch the Premier League soccer coverage
Rebecca wants to go check out skeleton
and she didn't do a whole run but I
won't give away what she did but we
precision it's crazy how close their
faces are to the ice and where how do
you control that some people say if
you're doing luge and you're on your
back you can't really see everything you
feel like you have less control I'll
tell you this one of the u.s. athletes
actually who carried the flag a week and
a half ago and luge athlete told me that
they trained to keep their next strong
with a thirty pound plate from weight
lifting on their forehead because you
have to keep your neck is so strong and
tree think about doing that so your
training
Mike Tirico joining us live from South
Korea that leads me into curling and of
course the performance-enhancing drug
controversy now here's my theory Mike
before you don't tell me being the
esteemed journalist that you are yeah I
think if you wanted a if you want to be
treated as a real sport and as a real
athlete somebody's got a test positive
for steroids Mike your thoughts there
you go into the category of it's real
because you got to do something fake be
great right yeah you know I was asking I
guess it goes back to you may remember
this conversation of beta blockers for
nerve being used by golfers back even in
the 80s and 90s over some accusations of
that and that's where this was but it
does bring up an interesting political
part of this dam because it is an
Olympic athlete from Russia where they
are Russians will they be welcomed back
into the Olympic movement by the IOC for
the closing ceremony if one of the big
stories of the next week will the
Russian flag be allowed to be seen at
the closing ceremony because Russia has
gone through this penalty period if you
will by being banned from using the flag
of man of all that stuff at these games
because of this incident involving them
all sports curling will that change how
that thing shakes out next week so a lot
of people are watching that with great
interest remember where she gets a
spotlight in the world with the World
Cup coming up this summer is it how
would you assess the media's reaction
maybe overreaction
the lack of success by the USA team i
building
I think it's building when you know you
tell that it's the largest contingent of
athletes from any country to ever
compete in the Winter Games and you look
at ten medals now officially there will
be an eleven hockey team will win either
gold or silver when they play their gold
medal game against Canada in a couple of
days that's you compare that to 2400 won
by Norway and they added to that tonight
that that kind of doesn't sit well with
American fans and you know you may
remember back when George Steinbrenner's
spoke up in a Steinbrenner Commission
was started because US and let the
Gavin's weren't performing at the level
that other countries were I don't know
if we're there but I really think that
there's going to be a lot of
conversation speed skating USA struggled
in Figure Skating maybe only legends the
metals could be ice dancing so there are
the other traditional Olympic sports
that the US seems to be falling behind
and not thriving in and I think if the
medal count is 15 or 16 when this is all
said and done they're gonna be real
questions asked about what planning
steps need to be done better going
forward capable job out of you Mike
great - great to talk to you and
hopefully know you are my best average
friend that I've ever had you said so
much thank you bye okay it's that review
the Texas week is that a real fireplace
again you'll have to wait til Sunday
oh the question is between now and then
will I roast the corn yes okay you'll
know okay I I'm gonna guess you could
get into that fireplace if you wanted to
Mike and you would be okay it'd be okay
yes you know what I think I think
Stephen Colbert did that on an Olympic
set maybe oh six maybe in 2010 no before
is CBS days so I'm I will see maybe
maybe I can work myself into that or
roast a marshmallow I went like I got a
score one of the other
I would like that hey you don't break
it's fun watch go to bed and we'll be
watching later on tonight
thanks pal talk to you see you guys all
right that's Mike Tirico NBC sports
Olympic host yeah a little subtle humor
there with Mike yeah I've been I've been
texting him back and forth
I was once labeled as a capable football
host and so I I thought that I would
share that with Mike then he was a he
was doing a capable job as a host for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]